factorise there's only what they have to
do to factorize this right it's almost
there you just have to take out a factor
of X yeah I'm gonna be really really
cheap and say if I take out a factor of
X here and CR and I'm gonna is that okay
just in a hurry yeah once you've done
that i'm factorized okay I'm up to this
step asymptotes there are two categories
of asymptotes that I'm interested in
which is the easiest to work out
generally it's vertical in this case the
horizontal one is sports are easy to
determine but it's not always it's not
always sometimes it's a click as we'll
see okay the vertical is easy where is
the vertical I get vertical asymptotes
from discontinuities of the function
right so x equals negative two so I've
got my axes
I missed that drawing okay so okay
there's a vertical asymptote there is a
horizontal asymptote here what is it
it's y equals one now a number one the
reason is horizontal is because I look
at the degree of the numerator
denominator and they're the same okay so
as X climbs off to infinity and negative
infinity and doing they're growing at
roughly the same rate there's no two or
three or four more extra coefficient at
the front so that's why x squared over x
squared will just be one so I'm gonna
try and do this with a reasonable sense
of scale okay so there's my horizontal
asymptote symmetry don't worry about it
factorizations done asymptotes done
intercepts I'm looking at the numerator
right so I've got the origin which means
I've got the y intercept for free as
well and I've got x equals four if I'm
saying that x equals negative two then
that would be x equals two and that
would be x equals four
roughly okay
okay so far so good so I should put a
across the end that's before and that's
you're done my intercepts I didn't have
to worry about one-way intercepts
because I have already regions ok
regions now you can do this um again in
a quick way or in a slower way right
remember the things that I'm using to
get my regions are these factors up here
okay but the reason why the defect is
important is because they tell me where
I'm positive and where I'm negative okay
now X is a factor X take away 4 is a
factor X plus 2 is a factor and the next
plus 2 is a factor again okay I just
want to point out that last bit right if
X plus 2 is a fat dog twice think about
what X plus 2 or square figure out what
it looks like think about what kind of
factor line I would draw for that and
the answer is it's a parabola right it's
not quite positive definite because it
actually does hit the axis right there
okay but everywhere else it's positive
so what does it contribute to the
changing the sign of the whole thing
answer doesn't change anything right if
I divide by a positive number then
whether this is positive or negative
it's sign remains unchanged so therefore
I'm going to ignore my X plus 2 squared
I don't need to cloud my diagram which
is already going to get busy enough with
these two extra lines which are
superfluous if don't don't give me any
useful information so these two old ones
that I need so X is gonna pass through
there and X minus 4 is gonna pass
through there you carry that and just to
help me draw my regions nicely I'm gonna
put a vertical line through 4 so that I
can shape properly right and now I'm
ready to shave I mean you have to factor
lines that I need to worry about even
though I've got two extra ones but they
don't confuse anything so true negative
scuse me are positive sign up here as I
sorry also here is that
yes good I'd stop where the factory
lines change sign right because all the
way out here and even even I caught
myself right an easy thing to forget
that asymptotes don't necessarily change
the sign the axis doesn't necessarily
change the sign so I call myself there
but you can see why I go all the way up
to here because at that point in a lie
transition yeah I'm not two negatives
anymore I'm a positive negative which
means negative highlighters are really
good for this by the way I just don't
have highlights at work on this point
and then I transition past four and I
have two positives meaning above the
answers positive okay now at this point
you actually could get a pretty good
idea of where the graph goes okay but
you have an extra piece of information
from this guy over here which gives you
that just a little bit more detail I
know there's a stationary point okay
where is the stationary point it's at 1
minus 1/3 now does that fit with the
picture that we've got already well this
is 4 that's 2 so 1 would be about there
and if I said that that's y equals 1
then y equals negative 1/3 would be
something like that it's a bit okay now
it's not as hot as it looks ok now
remember but I've found all the
stationary points this is one of the
distinct advantages of having done
cockiness now ok so knowing that I've
got all the stationary points over here
what's happening to the left of the
asymptote clearly it has to do this it
has to do this now I know that I'm going
to be coming from above the asymptote
before I knew calculus what I had to do
was I had to like try and put in numbers
suitors I had to put him like say x
equals negative 10,000 or negative a
million and then I would notice this
number and I actually went through this
process with you we got our calculator I
would say oh look it's like one point
zero zero zero zero one it's just above
okay so I knew I was up here ok but now
that we know calculus we know like apart
from this the only other thing you could
do is it could do that
it could come from below but calculus
excludes that
why because there's no stationary point
I found is one and one only stationary
point so this can't possibly happen okay
so even though we could do this without
contest before calculus kind of makes it
more efficient and more precise okay
so that's what's happening on the left
easy enough transition to what happens
over here on the right um I have a look
at this part over here this putt easy
enough
I know I'm gonna be here okay like I
said before you don't need the second
derivative to know this is gonna be a
local minimum right like how could it
possibly be a local maximum just imagine
if I tried to draw it as a mass it would
do something like that right but hold on
then I've got to get back to this
asymptote right which would be another
turning point but I can't do that
Karlie's I found is one and one only
turning point you see what I mean
so I didn't need to appeal to the second
derivative to know that what I knew from
just regular curve sketching in the
regions tells me this has to be a
minimum okay so it's gonna go up and
it's gonna approach this asymptote so
here's how I draw it I'm gonna be pretty
flat here and I'm gonna go towards the
asymptote okay what else can it do it
can't approach the asymptotes for the
top because again that would need
another turning point what happens here
on the left of my turning point well
I've got to come up here towards this
asymptote right in fact that's all I
have to do okay so therefore carefully
from this stationary point and then I
approach and of course I can blow
through that horizontal asymptote with
their problems because the horizontal
asymptotes only tells me about the
extremities positive and negative
infinity so he doesn't care about what
happens to you in fact you can let y
equal one and you can go ahead and solve
this quadratic I don't know what
actually now you're gonna get but you'll
get one okay